I also about your character Rizzoli &
Isles you on that scene you have some
racy love scenes some very sexy sexy
scenes and I'm not in that world I'm
here I conduct professional interviews
and I think I do a crackerjack job Oh
knock it off thank you but that that's
something I don't even know how you do
that like how do you you know how do you
create that that that moment on camera
with all these people standing around
it's really hard you know it will say in
the script something like their eyes
meet and it's as if the world stopped
and then it's too intense and they have
to break away what do you mean what do
you do so I struggle with that because
there's different there's different ways
in which I was getting I was giving it
to you right there
[Applause]
yeah an old cat going to sleep I'm
serious like what do you was gonna say I
mean it depends it depends what level
you want to take it to like there's the
sort of you know koi well first of all
we have to do let me need a line like a
mundane line anything a mundane life
anything okay oh I want to say I would
like to buy a bag of onions okay if
you're good you should be able to do
things
okay so you know the the light coy
giggle one would be is it I want to buy
a bag of onions I need to buy a bag of
Lemnos
you know you're quarreling with the
writing I worked for years on this line
to get a right have to get the line
though whatever line you want to say
that's why I need to go I need to go and
buy a bag of my Nan's there has to be a
giggle there has been like a you know
what can you force you to not look at me
poor women say that to me
I can't walk through a department store
without getting that hang out in a
changing room without getting
all right so which way am I going on
this way let me bring up some intensity
let's give it a real lion why don't you
just say what's ever what's a real good
line that you would say what's that come
on Andy help us out here what's a line
that you'd really should really say to
me if she was I wouldn't do this anymore
I can't do this anymore that's great do
this anymore so we'll do the angry I
want to tear your clothes apart I can't
do this anymore
go all right I can't do this anymore
you're hurting me
[Applause]
what kind of creepy we like slip in your
hair there's a reason I was a virgin
until I was 40 not kidding oh wow